[Music]
sam bankman freed is a 29 year old
american expat who had lived in hong
kong for the last few years but actually
just recently moved to bermuda he's
notable for a number of reasons but i
think most critically he is the richest
20-something in the world and the
richest person in all of crypto with a
net worth of 22.5
billion dollars
what's most interesting about the way he
raised this money is that unlike a lot
of people that got into bitcoin very
early on he started relatively late he
did not purchase his first bitcoin until
the year uh 2017 when he found a way to
sort of arbitrage uh differences in the
price of bitcoin between us and japanese
exchanges sometimes buying it and then
selling it at a 30 markup
he did this over and over again until he
built a small fortune and then he used
that in conjunction with some venture
capital that he raised to launch an
exchange called ftx
ftx just set a record for the largest
private raise in crypto history it
brought in 900 million dollars and an 18
billion valuation
sam's inclusion in the billionaires list
is really notable because for one thing
the only person in the world that has
ever gotten so rich so quickly is mark
zuckerberg who everyone has has heard of
and i think that really speaks to
um the way that he was able to time the
market to take advantage of the first
mainstream bow run in 2017 where bitcoin
went up from about twenty five hundred
dollars to close to twenty thousand in
just over six months
and then how he was able to roll that
into building an exchange that caters to
more active traders that trade higher
amounts at higher frequencies and and
he's really in some ways become a king
maker in in the industry
[Music]
i first started looking into crypto uh
not because of anything to do with
blockchain technology um it just seemed
like a good trading opportunity that
that was sort of what my background was
and there are lots of signs that it was
a space that had a ton of demand and a
ton of excitement and interest and
volume but not very much liquidity
and what that means is there's a pretty
significant chance that
customers are not getting great prices
when they're trading for that same
reason there's a potential of mine to be
made providing liquidity to those um you
know being uh being a market maker doing
arbitrage and trying to to sort of
increase the efficiency and liquidity of
crypto markets globally um that did turn
out to be true but it also quickly
became clear that the space was in need
of better infrastructure
when you think about the infrastructure
in crypto
a lot of it is the exchanges they
combine a lot of different business
models together and it seemed like a
really compelling opportunity to try to
jump in and build something better
he's a really interesting subject to
report on for a number of reasons i mean
first of all
his appearance he's only 29 years old
and he typically wears a t-shirt or a
sweatshirt that has the ftx logo on it
khaki shorts and he has this big kind of
poofy hair it's funny when we got a
quote from tom brady for the story who
is an ftx endorser and owns ftx
stock uh he said the first thing that
jumped out to him about sam when he saw
him on tv before they had even met is
the fact that he needs a haircut
the second thing that really stood out
is is his transparency i mean he's very
open to talking and and the reason
i i think is because he's raising all
this money
for a particular reason he's a believer
in a element of philanthropy known as
effective altruism where
adherents rely on the use of data and
modeling to find objective ways to do
the most good possible with their money
there's a few different roles that
somebody can play as an effective
altruist and he's chosen to be what's
known as an earn to giver which means
he's going to try to earn as much money
as he possibly can so that he can give
it to
people that are involved in
actual charities to give the money away
and have the most positive impact
in the end my my goal is is to
do as much good as i can for the world i
you know mostly what what i think about
is
what role should i be playing here
and i think the most impressive people i
know the people who i've
uh the most respect for and um
uh and and and who who are maybe doing
the most good for the world are are the
people who are really taking charge of
some of these initiatives um to to
combat
some of the biggest problems that that
we're facing as a society
but
you know another way that that one kind
of impact is is by helping to to fund
some of these causes and you know that
that's what i've been doing so i've uh
you know i got into
finance in the first place um to try and
maximize the amount that i can donate to
uh to some of the most effective causes
you know i'd certainly love to be
spending more time
thinking directly about
what these projects can be working on um
but
you know right now
there are a lot of really impressive
people doing that i wish there were way
more
my main role right now is to do what i
can to help support them
financially or or any other way that i
can
the idea of when
a philanthropist decides to stop earning
and starts giving it away
is a question that has plagued
billionaires for for a very long time
and it's something that's very
uh applicable to effective altruists
especially earned to givers because
their job or i guess their
self-appointed job is to just make as
much money as possible this would mean
that sam has very little say in where
the money goes or how it's spent he's
just going to make as much as possible
and that's a really interesting question
because
that's not the same model that other
corporate titans have taken i spoke with
a
philosopher and a professor at princeton
known as peter singer who is sort of
seen as one of the fathers of this
effective altruist movement and and he
said it's a very individual decision and
it's hard to
know what the right thing to do is he
spoke to me about bill gates and how
bill decided to step down from running
microsoft to run the gates foundation
which is very much a full-time job and
he told me it's really hard to kind of
do the counter factual and wonder was
that the right decision obviously
microsoft is still doing well but
perhaps it would be doing even better if
he decided to stay in that role and not
turn it over to steve ballmer
this is the dilemma that's
sam's going to be coming back to time
and time again especially if and when
his wealth grows and becomes more liquid
he actually told us right now that he
has uh only about two hundred thousand
dollars in the banking account in the
story we wrote that one way that sam is
very much like a 29 year old is that
he's remarkably cash poor
but uh assuming that his business
ventures go as planned at some point
he's going to have to wonder if it makes
sense for him to give away the money or
if he's happy to keep trying to earn as
much as possible and give it to trusted
third parties and partners
to give it away
[Music]